So we're going through the development of the theory and practice of organic
chemistry,
generation by generation.
We started with Lavoie,
ca and then,
but say alias and Galea sock and Davy.
And last time we did do ma and Lebeck and Buller and now we're onto the next
generation.
People that were born around night,
1830 and the new developments are going to be valence and benzene.
Remember in this list,
things that are in bold face or experimental and things that are theoretical or
in,
in normal face surveillance and,
and benzene is experimental.
But what we're interested in is the theory of benzene here and the people who
are associated with this are our goose Keka lay.
And you've all heard of calculate structures and calculate benzene.
And he's memorialized on the front of the building here at born in 1829 but few
of you probably have heard of Archibald Cooper who was,
is not on the front of the building and was born two years later in 1831.
This is Cooper as a student.
Uh,
he lived to a reasonable age,
61 years old,
but everything he did,
he did early.
He was a sort of a dilettante's student.
He was a native of Scotland and studied in Edinburgh,
but also went to Berlin often and he studied classics and metaphysics logic,
moral philosophy,
went to a lot of concerts.
But while in Berlin he got fascinated by chemistry.
So in 1855,
he became a student chemist.
And in 1856,
he went to Paris to work with boards.
Who was the other leading,
uh,
French chemist and worked indeed on salycilic acid as you have done,
in 1858,
while in boards lab,
he got fired for reasons that you'll see and he went back to Scotland and tried
to make a career there,
but Sooni had a mental breakdown and the rest of his life he didn't do anything.
Okay.
But what he did in 1858 is really something.
So he didn't get a stone on the front of our building.
But in this,
built in this,
on this building,
which,
uh,
is to ladder at least was a few years ago in Kirkintilloch,
which is about eight miles northeast of Glasgow in Scotland.
There's a stone and it says this black marks the birthplace of Archibald's Scott
Cooper,
who's brilliant,
pioneering contributions to chemical theory if one for him,
international renown and whose genius stifled by an early illness,
was denied the opportunity of consummation
when he was recovering from his first break down,
he went fishing on this,
uh,
Andrick water north of Glasgow and got sunstroke,
which even for the rest of his life,
and that's where he lived.
His mother nursed him for his final 33 years in this house in Kirkintilloch.
So this is the paper.
He tried to publish it in French.
He's,
he submitted it to,
to his boss vortex in the hopes that he would put it in the French journal,
but for its thought,
it was not such a,
there was a little a rash as a paper and put it in his desk to cool off for a
while.
And in the meantime,
calculate published,
which irritated Cooper no little.
And he,
uh,
he told a words what he thought about it,
which was why he got sacked.
Uh,
but he also published at an English and later it was published in French,
but this,
so this is the English version,
not the first version he wrote by Archibald's Scott Cooper.
And the first sentence already is,
is fascinating.
The end of chemistry.
That is the goal of chemistry is it's theory.
Not many people would have said that they would have had more practical
motivations for chemistry.
But,
uh,
Cooper was,
was,
uh,
a big thinker.
He said,
the Guide in chemical research is a theory.
It is therefore of the greatest importance to ascertain whether the theories at
present adopted by chemists are adequate to the explanation of chemical
phenomenon,
or at least based upon the true principles,
which ought to regulate scientific research.
So what were the theories that were prevalent at this time in eight by 1850
named one shine.
Dualism.
Okay.
The radical theory that was prevalent in Germany.
How about elsewhere?
Like France,
the substitution or tight or a unitary theory.
Okay.
So those were the big theories among those which have been lately developed.
There is one on account of it's apparent,
numerous merits which particularly claims investigation and respecting which we
deem that it would not be unprofitable were either new proofs of its scientific
value,
furnish door on the contrary should the considerations be adduced establishing
not only its inadequacy to the explanation but it's ultimate detriment to the
progress of science.
I allude to the system of types as advocated by Gearhart.
So Gerhardt and Lauren who are a slightly second level,
uh,
French chemists were the ones who really came up with the idea of the type
theory,
but do ma,
uh,
adopted and advocated that and was the leader.
Uh,
so any of that.
So this was the theory that was going on in the lab where he was,
uh,
present in Paris.
So page one oh six of this paper on the French type theory,
he said,
should the principal,
which is there in adopted be applied to common events of life,
it will be found that it is simply absurd.
Suppose that someone were to systematize the formation of letters into words
that formed the contents of a book where he,
to begin by saying that he had discovered a certain word which would serve as a
type,
I remember there were four types,
right?
Water,
ammonia,
uh,
hcl and hydrogen,
and from which by substitution and double d composition,
all the others are to be derived that he by this means not only can form new
words,
but new books and books almost.
I didn't finite up.
He would state certainly an empirical truth that as you can take some words,
substitute letters are pairs of letters or sets of letters for other letters and
get any words you want.
Okay.
At the same time,
however,
this method would judge by the light of common sense be an absurdity.
But if principle,
which common sense brands with absurdity is philosophically false and the
scientific blunder.
So this was not likely to make him popular in Paris
at the same time.
However,
I would say,
so here's,
here's what he was doing actually,
right?
The emperor's new clothes is the new guy on the block,
He's only been a chemist for two years,
only begun studying chemistry two years before and says what everybody is doing
is nonsense in Paris,
in France.
While how about in Germany?
That's where he was before in Berlin.
I can only remark that it does not merely an unprofitable figure of language,
but as injurious to science in as much as it tends to arrest to scientific
inquiry by adopting the notion that these cuase I elements,
what does he mean by the quasar elements?
What are they?
Compound radicals,
right?
Contain some unknown and ultimate power,
which it is impossible to explain.
That is,
okay,
so you've got radicals.
What holds the radicals together?
Right?
It stifles inquiry at the very point where an explanation is demanded by putting
the seal of elements of ultimate powers on bodies,
which are known to be anything but this.
They're definitely not elements cause you can burn them of course and get water
and CO2 and so on.
Okay,
so this was absolutely true on both counts,
both the French and the German theory,
but it was stated pretty undiplomatic Lee.
Right?
Especially for someone who'd only been studying chemistry for two years.
Maybe it took someone who was only studied in chemistry two years to see how
stupid it was.
Right?
But at any rate,
he got in trouble because of this.
What did he offer as an alternative to look at the properties of the elements
themselves,
not of radicals,
not of these planetary systems that were the types science demands,
the strict adherence to a principal in direct contradiction to this view,
that first principle without which research cannot advance a step,
dare not be ignored,
namely that a whole is simply the derivative of its parts.
So if you have to understand the elements and then you can understand assemblies
of elements from that,
that's not obviously true.
In fact,
I think you could make a pretty good argument that as you'd get things more
complicated,
they're not simply a sum of their parts.
But that's what he said as a consequence of this.
It follows that it is absolutely necessary to scientific unity in research to
consider these bodies as entirely derivative and as containing no secret
ultimate power,
whatever.
And that the properties which these so called quasars elements possess are a
direct consequence of the properties of the individual elements of which they
are made up.
So study the elements,
not the radicals.
And he began by saying he'll focus on carbon,
which is not surprising for an organic chemist and apply in this method.
I propose at present to consider the single element carbon.
This body is found to have two highly distinguishing characteristics.
One,
it combines with equal numbers of hydrogen,
chlorine,
oxygen,
sulfur,
etc. Would you agree with that?
How could he say so
it's because he wasn't dealing with the right atomic weights,
right?
It enters into chemical union with itself.
So those are the two things that it'll you unite with itself,
not just with other things.
The way dualism would like you to do and it combines with it has a certain
combining power.
These two properties in my opinion,
explain all that is characteristic of organic chemistry.
So 1858 marks that a new frontier in organic chemistry,
completely new revelation,
the Tetra Valence and self linking of carbon.
That's points one and two right?
That it combines with a certain number of other things and it can link to
itself.
Right now here he shows the formula of methane of co two and of carbon
tetrachloride,
but those are the atomic weight sees using in order to get these formulas.
Notice he says,
here are the whole four of hydrogen are not bound by a mutual affinity.
You know that they're not all collected together because you can substitute them
one by one.
Clo,
one chlorine to chloramines three chlorines for each element of hydrogen can be
substituted for one of chlorine and regular series beginning with the first
ending with the last,
the atoms of oxygen are on the contrary,
United in Pairs.
What does he mean by that?
That the oxygens are United in Pairs.
Why are they United in pairs in his formulas drawn by those curly brackets like
they had in type theory?
Yeah,
Angela,
they're probably one oxygen is,
wait,
it's happened.
Aha.
Because he had half of the atomic waste,
so they always came in pairs.
Right.
Take to get oxygen.
16 if he thinks oxygen's eight,
the atoms of oxygen or in pairs,
which will be more,
which will be more fully developed here after,
not in this paper,
but there was no hereafter because of his breakdown.
Okay.
And only for two atoms of oxygen to chloramines can be substituted thus.
So you can start with CEO to get phosgene and carbon tetrachloride in the same
manner with bodies that contain multiples of c two United dihydrogen.
So carbon is the same deal.
It always comes in payers,
right?
Because it's atomic way to six instead of 12.
Okay.
Take the inverse of this.
If the four atoms of hydrogen,
we're bound together,
we could evidently expect to form such bodies as h for cl four.
Right?
If the four were all held together and could make four bonds,
right,
then you could get h for cl four or these other compounds.
Uh,
one would naturally expect to find carbon substitute for chlorine.
Find bodies like h for cl two c two and so on.
These bodies are not only unknown,
but the whole history of hydrogen might be investigated and not a single
instance be found in favor of the opinion that it has any affinity for itself
when in union with another element.
Okay,
so that member getting all the chlorine is together was uh,
was Schindler's idea.
Okay.
So here,
now,
now that he have the idea that these atoms associate together,
it makes sense to talk about a structure,
right?
What's connected to what's connected to what,
you know,
the toe bone in the ankle bone and all that stuff.
Okay.
So now you could write structural formula.
So this was the,
these were the very first structural formula because before this there was no
such thing as structure.
Okay?
Thus,
mythic alcohol has this formula and [inaudible] alcohol has the other.
So now do you see the,
see the theme here,
what's he using to note bonds?
Three dots,
right?
Are a bond.
So he has a carbon bonded to three H's and also two o.
O.
H.
That's because oxygen is doubling,
right?
So we would write it this way,
or ethyl alcohol.
We would write that way
or this compound.
Now this one has a printer's error in it.
What is it and what's the printer's error?
What's the substance?
Sam,
could you read it off to me?
Start from the left.
Bottom left.
What is it?
What's the first group?
There's a carbon.
That's the single carbon,
right?
Yeah.
Methyl ch three right?
He doesn't draw the three bonds,
the hydrogen separately,
but it's clearly been seed bonded to three hydrogens.
What's next?
Keep going.
It's a c bonded to what?
The top left.
It's bonded to the methyl of course.
What else?
It's to the oxygen to a single oxygen.
All the we wrote to.
Right.
And what else is that carbon bonded to
nitrogen.
How many?
How many hydrogens are bonded to the top left?
Carbon?
The two.
So let's see.
H Three C H,
two o.
Now can someone help me out with the rest of it?
Ryan,
wouldn't that only just be one?
Cause it should be one old,
but he's got the different topic.
Wait,
John [inaudible] is on the far right.
Should be bonded to one another.
The printer lashed that out.
So it's symmetrical.
It's die,
ethyl ether.
Okay.
And it's the correct structure for it except for the printers there.
Now he says there is no reaction found where it is known that c two is divided
into two parts.
It is only consequent therefore to write as Gerhardt does C to simply as see it
being understood that the equivalent of carbon is 12 so he changed it in this
paper to be 12 so now he's formulas are going to be more like ours,
right?
Without the c two so he has gliss a formula for glycerin and one for
glycyrrhizic acid.
So let's do Gleiss Eric acid.
What do you see up at the top?
What's the top carbon?
Maxwell.
You say?
What's it bonded to?
The carbon at the top on the right
one.
Hydrogen,
H
and o h group Barbie,
another two o h groups
and the carbon below.
Right?
Because carbon can bond to carbon.
That's the special thing about it.
Okay,
so here's the one on the left in a formula nowadays,
and there's the one on the right and it turns out he gets a bit wrong because he
put two o h is on the top carbon and none on the middle one,
and it should be the other way around.
So in truth,
he should have changed those two.
Of course,
he had no way of knowing it.
And the same on the right.
Okay.
Somebody who's pretty close with his structure.
But probably the most remarkable thing is,
is structure for glucose,
which is shown here and which now he doesn't show the vertical bonds between
carbons.
He uses this curly bracket.
So that's a little reminiscent of type theory,
but clearly that's what he meant was the carbons to be bonded to carbon.
So that's the formula he wrote.
And that's the correct structure for glucose if it's hydrated.
Okay?
So you can add glucose is an Aldehyde Cho on the bottom,
double Bondo.
So you can add water to the Aldehyde that actually happens and you get the,
the structure he wrote here.
So He eats right if the glucose is in water,
right.
So He'd try yourself,
this is a good exercise for reviewing what we've been doing.
Try,
it's depending on how you define it as a two or a three step sequence of Homo
Lumo interactions that take water plus an Aldehyde into a dial,
which is what you have here.
So try that one out.
Okay.
And then the French version of the same paper,
which is we set up here in a little later,
he drew it this way.
And what do you notice is different now?
The two things different actually.
Yeah.
Now he's drawing single lines,
straight lines for bonds.
So this is the first time that was done.
None of these dotted lines anymore,
but there's a typo instead of drawing Oh,
h here and notice the uh,
yeah,
he's instead of drawing,
Ooh,
here for a second.
He's,
he,
he added,
he's got the wrong formula.
It's got h two there.
But this is really amazing that he got the correct structure for such a
complicated molecule in the very first paper where the idea of structure of
bonds all together was proposed.
So this is really amazing.
And uh,
and we owe to Cooper the idea of bonds and the notation we use to do them.
So here's old,
I'll cemetery in Kirkintilloch in Scotland yesterday and there are,
you see that this is the gravestone of Archibald Scott Cooper.
And down here
is your thank you note.
And those were the flower.
That's the Heather,
you bought the foot on his tombstone.
So that was our secret thank you note.
And we thank uh,
Susan through for,
for being our agent and delivering this yesterday.
Okay.
But on the front of the building,
Cooper doesn't get any notice at all.
It's only you guys that are in the know that can do that right on the front of
the building.
They say calculate.
So let's talk about Calculi and we'll also talk about Hoffman,
who we mentioned before is the guy in the top hat on the right end of that
picture in liebig slab in Giessen and Cannizzaro.
Okay.
This is a drawing that calculate made at the age of 13 by my standards.
That's a pretty darn good drawing.
And here's one he made at the age of 18 and he was,
he went to Giessen University to study architecture.
Right.
But while he was there,
or you went to [inaudible] lectures and got fascinated by chemistry and became a
chemist.
Okay.
He studied with that.
We can,
after he finished,
he wanted to go to Paris to study with the people there.
What do you think parent,
what do you think a liebig remember it's had worked with Gail Lewis socks,
so he knew from Paris.
What do you think he would tell leaving the young guy about to go off to Paris,
stay away from Doula perhaps.
Right?
What he said was there,
you will broaden your horizons there.
You will learn a new language there.
You will learn to know the life of a great city,
but there you will not learn chemistry.
But he went anyhow.
He also went to England and became widely acquainted with all the leading canvas
of the day.
Then he got a job in Heidelberg where he was from 1856 to 58 and he did research
on CACA deal.
That's that free radical involving arsenic are remarkable.
His student who,
who,
uh,
worked with him on that was a buyer who will talk about a lot later.
Uh,
that was Bahnson who was the big cheese in Heidelberg was the one he was
calculated was associated with,
uh,
and he did the work,
not in a laboratory but in the kitchen,
in his apartment at this work on our snake.
So in 1857 during while he was there,
he proposed a new type right based on carbon.
So carbon could have four things attached to it,
which you could substitute one for another.
Right?
So this was,
this was where he got the idea of carbon being something special,
the basis of a new type and that it was Tetra Vaillant.
Uh,
and ultimately he got onto the idea a year later that carbon could link to
itself.
So he had proposed the marsh gas type before coopers paper,
but this other one was essentially simultaneous,
just slightly later written,
but earlier published.
Here are his observations on Mr Cooper's new chemical theory.
In fact in two memoirs which have appeared in lead because the novel and I've
put forward different views which in my opinion should furnish a clearer insight
into the constitution of chemical compounds clearer than coopers.
I may be allowed to indicate that my first paper lays down the principal,
which I have called the basis city of Adam's.
We'd say valence if Mr. Cooper thinks he has discovered the cause of this
difference of basis city in the existence of a special kind of affinity.
I am the first to admit that I have no right to contest his priority in this,
but he was quick to say that he was the one that had the idea first and he went
on to quite a successful career in contrast to Cooper.
Here he is in Ghent.
That period during which he proposed the structure for benzene with a bunch of
people who we will talk about later,
or at least several of them we'll talk about later as the students and then he
became the leader in bond and a big new chemistry institute there.
Here he is in 1872 and we'll talk a lot about this,
this guy on the,
on the right here.
So he became a really a prime leader in chemistry.
Uh,
now facts,
ideas and words.
Words means nomenclature.
So these new ideas needed new words and not just the words written out with
letters,
but notation.
What symbols are you going to write for these things?
And,
uh,
a further development that is actual physical models that you could put together
right to d to show what you're talking about with molecules if they have
structure.
So Hoffman was great with language.
He actually went and became a leading professor in,
in,
uh,
the Royal College of chemistry in London because Prince Albert,
you know,
Victoria and Albert Albert was a German.
So he,
he,
uh,
had a lot of connections with the German Chemistry and went to Lebeck leaving,
said,
Hoffman is a great guy.
You should get him.
So they got him.
So he came to London and it was,
was a completely fluent in English and very good at languages all together.
And he had the idea of systematizing the names of hydrocarbons.
Uh,
so,
uh,
he was going to base it on Latin roots.
So for will be court,
right?
We,
we,
what do we say for,
for butane,
right?
We talked about that last time.
So core Tane is his,
the start and then you can start pulling hydrogens off and have names for the
radical.
So if you pull one hydrogen off its core teal cause eel,
remember is that root?
That means radical.
And then you can pull a second hydrogen.
Often you have core team and they pull a third agent office,
core,
teen eel and then core time Choriti Neil core tone,
core Toneil for tune core Toneil what was this system?
How can you remember which one is core to yeah,
it's the vowels in order.
Aei,
Iou.
And we preserve the a,
the e and the eye.
Although we write why instead of Ifr.
Alcaide right.
That's where it came from,
from Hoffman.
But the court didn't stick because Butte was well established by then.
Okay.
Now how about calculators?
So that's words.
How about notation?
So in the paper where he proposed benzene in 1865 while he was in Ghent,
he says,
for in a footnote for glider for greater clarity,
I am presenting at the end of this note,
a table giving graphical formula for most of the substances mentioned.
The idea that these formulas are designed to express is rather well known now,
so it will not be necessary to dwell upon it.
I'm keeping the form that I adopted in 1859 when expressing for the first time
my views on the atomic constitution of molecules.
So 1859 is at the time he was proposing valence is on 1858 was that remember?
So this is now a five,
six years later and he's,
he's applying it to benzene.
This forum is nearly identical,
that which monsieur warts used in his beautiful lectures on chemical philosophy.
It seems to be preferable to the modifications proposed by Macy or low Schmidt
and crump Brown.
So let's first look at what low Schmidt Dude and from Brown.
So here's,
here's a,
here's what they said,
the witch calculate his superior.
Well first,
let's think,
what should a formula show,
right?
What's the very first thing a formula should show?
It has to correspond with the facts,
right?
So what facts do you deduce about a molecule?
What should the formula show?
Kevin?
What elements are in,
what elements are there?
Carbon,
hydrogen,
oxygen,
glory,
nitrogen,
whatever.
Okay,
what else?
Chai.
The ratio that elements like the ratio or the elements,
right?
The Burt's Eylea solver also had this,
but what's it going to be new?
I think I've got that there.
Right?
Composition,
the elements and the number of addicts.
What next?
Now with you've got the new theory,
the valence theory.
Sherwin,
the structure.
What do you mean by the structure?
[inaudible]
positioning.
You mean like x,
Y,
Z coordinates?
You could,
you could write,
you know,
numbers.
Here's the origin.
I'm going to give you these,
this 1.238 and so on.
What then the which,
ah,
which ones are connected to one another,
right?
Not their positions in space,
but this is connected to this.
This valence goes there and so on.
Okay.
So Brett's alias was already fine for composition.
But now we also need to show constitution.
That's the second C is constitution,
which means the nature and sequence of bonds.
Now sequences clear.
This is bond to this bond or this.
What do I mean by the nature of the bond?
How could the bonds differ in their nature?
Single double.
Triple.
Right?
Okay,
so a man,
you need to be able to show isomers which presale?
Yes.
Couldn't show.
Okay.
So here's low Schmidt.
This is low Schmidt's formula 1861 for a CDEC acid.
Can you understand it?
Andrew?
What do you say?
No hope.
What do you think?
And stuff on the left is
pardoning ch ch three right?
So the size is something about the weight,
right?
So see h three what's it bonded to see?
Same size.
What's it bonded to?
O H and what?
Special double bonds.
So he's got a way of showing a double box,
right?
So we could easily understand it.
Okay.
Now here's from Brown.
Now that's benzoic acid and prompt Brown's paper.
So the Coh is even clearer than it was in low Schmidt,
right?
What's a double and single bought the same thing we use now.
Okay,
what's different is the c six part and five hydrogens attached to it,
but we don't really know how the c six is arranged all ago.
He also shows this one for a funnel,
which is a Benzie with a hydroxyl group on an Ooh.
So there you'll see a ring was double single,
double single,
and h is attached to all the carbons except for one,
which has always,
so that's easy to understand,
shy,
because if you say carbon has four,
then you have to figure out where the fourth one is,
right?
If it's associated with three Adams,
but could make four bonds,
it must make due to one of them.
Let's the idea anyhow.
Or it could be,
you know,
that they all go to the center of the ring,
the fourth one and so on.
There are other ideas too.
Okay.
Or here is a reaction in a,
a crumb Brown's notation.
So it's an Aldehyde.
You add a homo of cyanide and a proton to the o and you get that compound,
a Cyan,
oh hydrogen as it's called.
So this is this.
It's almost identical.
What difference is it from our current,
how different is it?
We don't draw circles around the elements anymore that makes it faster to draw.
Otherwise it's essentially the same.
Okay.
Or here he says there are two kinds of alcohols,
true alcohol,
which can lose water and give an olefin or olefin hydrate,
which can lose water and given the same Olefin,
what's the difference between the true alcohol and the Olefin hydrate?
How are they isomers
Russell,
right?
The position that Eoh relative to the AR,
So he's explaining isomers here too.
So those are pretty good.
But calculate says his is ever so much better.
This is calculated structure of benzene from that same paper.
Every says at the end,
I'm going to give my superior formula.
So what in the heck
is he talking about?
Eric,
you got any idea?
So what do you think that is,
Eric?
No idea.
Well,
you don't have much to work with in benzene.
What do you have it?
C Six h six right,
so that's got to either be carbon or hydrogen.
Which do you think
the top left there?
No idea.
Anybody got an idea?
Why do you say carbon?
Kate?
Okay.
Ah,
it's showing up above here in the schematic when it's showing double bonds
between carbon and then the single bond and a double bond than a single bond
double bond and well,
let's go.
That's open chain and this is closed chain.
What are these arrows on the end?
Ah,
those are the ones that look back then attached to one another somehow to make a
ring.
Okay.
You think he's trying to give to imply Cartesian coordinates for the location of
every atom by worried draws these symbols,
right?
He's,
he's trying to show x,
Y,
Z coordinates.
What do you think Nate?
They heave.
Thank you.
Thanks.
He's showing that are not
either of you.
He's got a spot there and he's got x,
y.
I mean you can say,
right,
here's the x axis.
Here's the y axis.
It says certain coordinates that that,
that,
that you think he thinks that if he had a microscope and can see it,
that's the,
where those Adams would be.
In fact,
is it physical positioning showing
Kelsey,
you got an idea,
you think he thinks he showing where,
where are these atoms are actually located in space?
What is he showing?
Yeah,
Sherwin.
The seek what?
What's bonded to water,
whether it's single bond or double bond.
He showing constitution the nature and sequence of bonds,
not positions of Adam's certainly not.
Okay.
And then the little ones are hydrogens,
right?
So you've got double the length of one of these things is how many beds,
how many valence is it has,
right.
For long for carbon,
only one long for hydrogen and Tangency then means a bond,
right?
So this is c h double bond,
c,
h,
single bond,
c h,
double bond and so on.
And then you get to the end,
you go back to the beginning.
Okay.
Now he then chose chlorinated benzene because chlorine is also monovalent,
right?
So you can substitute for hydrogen and then you can have dye chloro benzene.
Two or try or tetra or so right now is he showing isomers here?
That is in this case,
if you substituted this one or chlorine instead of that one,
same thing or different things.
If you believe,
what if you believed that this was a picture of things in space,
they'd be different.
Right?
But if all you're interested in is what's connected to what buy single a double
bonds,
then it's the same.
You have the same pattern either way.
How about for the dye chloro
would there be isomers of that?
Ah,
you could get different sequence,
right?
They could be adjacent carbons that have fluorines are next to adjacent or or
beyond that.
Right?
So you could,
you could use this system to talk about isomers.
So how many isomers now,
what do you think?
Calculate thought.
What do you think you thought about how many isomers of Chloro benzene there
are?
Do you think you thought there were many?
Just what?
Yes.
I'm going to show you.
Okay.
He thinks his,
his system is superior.
Now he also used his system in the same paper.
He did a lot of formulas,
but he showed these compounds like this one.
What's that group on the left?
What's the group here?
What is that?
What's this Adam
ch three what's this ch two
o.
H.
Two O is two units long,
right?
So ch three ch two ch two O.
H.
I'll.
Cool.
Proppy league.
Propyl alcohol.
Okay.
Now what's this one?
C.
H Three
C H.
Three C.
H.
O.
It's all cool.
Made Teal at the league.
Methyl ethyl alcohol.
So this would be ethyl alcohol,
the part on the top,
but we've got n methyl substitute and it,
and notice he's having to change his formula,
right?
Because now these are horizontal tangent sees that are bonds,
but this vertical Tangency doesn't count as a bond.
So it's getting a little complicated to explain to students.
Right.
Okay.
What's the next one?
C h three
what's this c double bond.
O.
C.
H.
Three.
So that's our old friend acetone.
And what's this one?
Ch Three ch Oh,
age,
right?
C H.
Three al.
Cool.
Our say Tony.
So it's the alcohol you get by adding two hydrogens to acetone.
Now,
what do you think about this?
Do you see anything interesting?
This one is ch three c,
h.
O,
C.
Three.
This one is ch three Ch,
ch,
three o h.
So okay,
what do you say?
Ah,
they're the same nature and sequence of bonds,
right?
That one's what we know of.
That's that one,
that one,
that one.
But uh,
but the last and number 28 here are the same thing,
but he draws different formulas for them.
So his system is not showing isomerism properly.
Right.
He drew these different,
he didn't say they were the same.
Right.
And they were thought to be different because when you do one,
when you prepare it one way and where are your parents?
Another way you get a different boiling points say or something.
I actually don't know what the data was,
but there was some difference.
It said there were these two different compounds.
Did you ever get a wrong boiling point?
So did they write it just turned out the experiment was wrong.
But that shows that his system is not as good as these other systems.
But whatever.
He said.
Okay.
Now how about physical models of of uh,
molecules?
Well,
here's a great patent that was issued by the u s patent office to Samuel M Games
of Glasgow,
Kentucky in 1868 and we could read about his description of what so good about
this.
He says now if a class thus instructed be it the recitation bench.
So here's our recitation bench,
right,
and one of them has requested to form carbonic acid.
You will walk quickly to the table in front where the box is open and place on
one of the shelves.
A cube marked six and two marked eight carbon one oxygen too.
If requested to form Lyme,
he will place on the shelf a cube march 20 and another marked eight oxygen.
These being the elements of life,
these cubes being all placed in contact and the pupil being asked what have we
now answers carbonate of line.
All right.
Okay.
Another pupil may then be asked to give the proximate analysis for carbonate of
line and the cubes before him will indicate the answer and fix it in his memory.
It is composed of one equivalent of carbonic acid,
22 and one of line 28 you just pull them apart.
You see what the approximate analysis is.
Another may be requested to give the ultimate analysis and by the same means he
is furnished with the answer.
Carbonic acid is composed of one out of of carbon to have oxygen and Lyme is
composed of one atom in calcium and one of oxygen.
The intelligent educator will see at a glance that this,
that in this chemical alphabet,
he has the means of at once arresting the attention of his class and converting
what had hitherto been an irksome task into a pleasant recreation.
The atomic theory,
the characteristics of affinity,
the law of multiple proportions,
the nomenclature I saw Marizza et Cetera may all be learned in half the time
required here too far and learned so as not likely ever to be forgotten.
Now,
what do you think with this show?
The atomic theory that molecules are substances are composed of atoms.
Does it show it?
Yeah.
Okay.
How about the characteristics of affinity?
Single,
double,
triple bond valence and so on show that
not have any audience way that I can see.
So I doubt that one.
How about the law of multiple proportions?
Remember what the law of multiple proportions was?
Do you have the same elements?
If you have a parts of ADP,
parts of B and so on,
all that stuff then what a d will be and so on.
Yeah.
Max,
they only show one oxygen use notation.
Pardon me?
Did quickly know what the exact um,
massive auction was because they only had one in,
isn't
notate everything here is,
oh,
so it's okay.
They're right proportions,
right?
But multiple proportions that you have to know something about.
Uh,
what,
how many of one associates with how many of another,
which isn't obvious here.
Okay.
Uh,
nomenclature,
well maybe calcium oxide and so on.
CO2,
I saw Marissa them that you can have the same things differently arranged.
Well,
obviously you can put the blocks on top of one another or beside one another,
but how do you know how many you should do right then?
Not very clear to me that this system works well.
So those models are good for some things,
but not good for an awful lot of things.
Okay.
Now,
James Dewar in Scotland,
a student had the idea of using brass strips to show models and in fact he could
put these black balls on.
He said to make a combination look like an Adam,
a thin round disk of black and brass can be placed under the central nut.
I think that's really cute to look like an Adam as if he knew what an Adam
looked like.
Right.
Okay,
so then he drew the,
he made these models from his strips of Ben's a possible structures of benzene,
right.
You can see where the atoms are and the four valence is on every carbon and what
they,
which direction they go.
That particular one,
that compound,
that structure was actually prepared about a hundred years later and when it
was,
it was called dewar benzene.
Right.
That one's interesting.
It's got a four center bond,
four carbons,
all sharing the same bond,
right?
Hoffman,
the guy remember who is good at language and was in London.
The,
his last lecture in London was at the royal institution.
The place where Farah Day was and where a Davey had been and did the experiments
that electrolysis.
So he gave this public lecture where he use croquet balls for model for Adam
models with,
with sticks stuck in him and he colored them.
And this system he chose is the one we still use for what color?
The atoms are white for hydrogen.
Red For oxygen,
blue for nitrogen,
black for carbon.
Okay.
So here's part of the lecture he gave.
So he,
he would build molecules before your very eyes.
It start with a hydrogen,
but an oxygen on and another hydrogen low.
He's made water.
Right.
Or he could make marsh gas methane
or he could show that,
uh,
the oxides of,
of Hcl.
So you start with Hcl,
but he could take it apart and put an oxygen in between or put two oxygens or
three or four oxygens in between to go from hydrochloric to Hypo.
Cloris to Cloris to chloric to per caloric.
So this is like Lavoie Z,
right?
Going to different levels of oxidation.
Unfortunately,
those aren't the structures,
right?
What really happens is that the unshared pair of chlorine couldn't share with
oxygen to give that,
to give this,
which is the active ingredient in Clorox bleach.
Or you could use another unshared pair of chlorine to put another oxygen or
another for another and get the oxidase oxidizing agent that gay Lusaka used the
glory.
Or You could put a last one,
and this is an explosive,
in fact,
ammonium perchlorate.
AP is a component of the military explosives.
Notice that in Hoffman's thing,
you could have put 15 oxygens in a row if you could have reached high enough,
but you can only go to four here because that's how many unshared bears chlorine
has chloride as to use.
Okay,
but he,
then he showed the Clo the chlorination of marsh gas,
so mano chlorinated dechlorinated try chlorinated and Tetra chlorinated marsh
gas.
Now this is interesting because the,
for the dye chloro,
you could imagine having two isomers with these models,
right?
They could,
the chlorine's could be near one another or opposite one another.
Right?
Now,
some years later,
there was an exhibition in London and they,
and they showed molecular models.
By this time Hoffman was back in Germany,
but they got,
they got a guy in Spain to make some Hoffman style models.
Manuel Gonzalez Rodriguez from Madrid made this set.
And here's,
uh,
Ma,
chloro methane made from that set.
What's the difference between these off he says,
according to Hoffman here,
so go an awl Hoffman,
right?
What's the difference?
And Yeah,
they're not 90 degrees from one another there 109 and a half degrees from
wonder.
It's a tetrahedron,
not a square plane right.
Now,
what does that say about isomers?
So supposedly substitute another chlorine and there's a dye chloro there's a
different diet chloro there's a different diet chloro how about it?
They're just rotated from one another.
They're not different.
Right?
So depending on whether it's square,
planar or tetrahedral,
you'll get different numbers of isomers.
That's neat because it gives you a tool for telling whether it's Square Planar,
a tetrahedral,
right?
So you can get structure from analysis.
So,
but these are these constitutional models.
Try to show the nature and sequence of bonds for Hoffman,
not the arrangement in space and not for Hoffman.
And not for the guy that made these models.
They weren't trying to explain isomers in that way.
All they were trying to show was the same thing.
You draw in these pictures,
the nature and the sequence of bonds,
whether they're single or double,
triple and what's associated with what.
So that comes a little later trying to get to the arrangement space.
But the PS,
the raise,
the stance of Hoffman's lecture was this.
Then if you take these croquet ball models and make the Ola Fiat Gas,
which we talked about last time,
it's got to spare.
Valence is,
and if you add chlorine,
you can get the Dutch liquid,
the dyke chloro ethane.
But remember what we saw last time he called Ola find gas and unfinished or not
saturated.
We now call it unsaturated molecule and it's reactive because of these dangling
valances and we now know why it's that way that he's got the wrong structure,
right?
It should be ch two ch two not ch ch three and we know about homos and Lumos
now,
but that was what he really showed was that the model had something completely
new that no one anticipated.
It could explain what this new,
what new quality is he associated with the models,
what elements are there,
what ratio there in right.
How they're linked to one another,
single double,
triple bonds.
What's he adding?
Reactivity.
Right?
So it's something new.
So the whole history is adding new things,
new properties to the models,
and there are more to come.
Okay.
That's it.